[Music]
welcome to frederies
your favorite show online
that's our tagline now your favorite
show online yeah okay cool
we could probably do better than that i
like that tag your favorite show online
today's episode is sponsored by honey we
got
another sponsor heck yeah enjoying honey
and honey's like pretty legit so
i love honey i actually use it i've
never had an ad read before but it
actually is
i love it i love to shop and i'm lazy
and it's perfect because it saves you
money and you can be like we'll do the
ad read yeah not even but i
actually just love it i don't know what
the attorney is i love honey love honey
okay we should have some honey for our
grilled cheese
okay so today's pretty actually exciting
episode last
episode if you guys watched to the end
we started playing the trivia
it was super fun i have to say i'm
pretty impressed by how competitive i
was
i'm feeling much better i lost my cash
i don't remember the cash say what but
we can still donate or something well
you brought three thousand dollars cash
what do you mean you lost
well we're like in the middle of a move
and i don't know where it is i lost the
broken out it was in which is more
important but the cash was inside but
it's fine it's in a box somewhere you
think
um yeah somewhere so you you think it's
still in your possession it's just you
yeah yeah yeah for example okay good
good good good i've got to bring it i
also love the tank
oh yeah so also so i wanted i wanted to
be supportive and i got my sad boy
t-shirt
but i was kind of perplexed because i've
never got a shirt
where the tag why are there two it's
inside out
okay people have been emailing me
they're like i need to read like i swear
they asked me and i'm like that's all
it's supposed to be we're supposed to be
edgy you're just supposed to cut the
tags off
dude i was like what the [ __ ] thank you
for supporting i was so i was there
solution oh easy yeah they they're easy
to rip off but i was just like
i thought they made a mistake i was like
wow no but let's see how edgy we are
we're inside out okay
no i like the idea i mean it's cool i
just didn't realize
we were the same shirt there's so many
options i could have chosen i like that
we have the same shirt you can get them
at savages.com
i'm a sad boy fan are you you have a new
music video out mall and drive it's our
last one for a couple months but hey
that's a it's a good push it's good out
there i did in
yeah go check out the new sad boy song i
am a sad boy
is that what you call your fans sad men
i'm a sad man
what's the name of your stance oh our
stands yeah
we don't really have any sad boy i'm a
sad boy okay yeah i like that i mean i'm
the sad boy so i think of them as just
like
sad my depressed friends oh
no you gotta think i know i like the
idea i'm trying to think of a title for
them like
pathetic losers i'm a pathetic loser
do you want to do a sad boy 2005 music
collab because you're very musical
you're really good at music actually
i'm in what kind of music did you listen
to because everyone was kind of pissed
that you did not know mcr in gerard way
i know i said listen i can't control i
can't go back in history
and change history i don't know what to
tell you i like classic rock
like what what do you know what i was
listening to back then i was listening
to like motown and oldies and stuff
really yeah i know you wanna leave me
but i refuse to let you go
that kind of stuff if i got a begging
bleed for your sympathy i don't mind
cause you mean that much to me let me
have to pray
sweet darling we don't come girl then
we're gonna get claimed for being so on
pitch
i think we're pretty good i think we're
like above average we would make
such a f if funny horrible but funny
we should do something no acapella group
can we do acapella i love acapella
i love acapella so much i love that
what's the one that was like
that one she's got eyes that seems to me
reminds me of you know what i'm talking
about from step brothers
what that's not you motown
that's gunnings and roses
yeah step brothers they have a family of
four that do that song yeah but you know
that's not
the original song that's like a rocks
okay we established i'm the rocker and
you're not you're the most okay but then
why are you singing a cappella
acapella song from step brothers it's a
classic scene oh my god really
gross ethan in the comments we're not
knowing this either because this is a
famous pop culture reference that every
single person knows i don't even like
them
brothers are you kidding me wait are you
trying to claim the stepbrothers the
cornerstone of of cultural
norms thank you a thousand percent
i don't even like will ferrell johnson
that much but like i know all the scenes
and lines from step brothers i do think
that's unusual that you're so familiar
with step bro
you don't have one quote you know from
step brothers it's the [ __ ] catalyst
yeah i can say this
more activities more space for
activities is that our life
yeah hello okay and they moved the bed
over yeah okay so you know
so it's classic i'm gonna disagree on
that
but i think we should do acapella group
okay
honestly i'm really good at it i have
some friends in pentatonix mitch
grossi's a friend of mine oh
well then people will not even remember
who they are once we started we saw
they're like grammy award winners
i dated i'm just you did avi i threw
yeah i threw his stuff out of my house
because he was an [ __ ] but
did he ever sing to you he was one of
those don't ever date a singer he just
sang all the time and he'd always have
his guitar out just ready to sing
is that annoying it's annoying it's like
get a life dude for a minute
because he was awesome so all he did was
like
dated we hooked up on tinder and hung
out a lot so i don't want just to
clarify we weren't like boyfriend
girlfriend but we did like hook up he's
like lived with me because he was cheap
and like all this stuff like that but
wait so are they they're not making
money those guys because there's so many
of them he quit no mitch is balling
mitch and
no that's that's the problem with being
in a band with like 20 people though is
that like
even if you make a ton of money you're
not you're not going to get that much
there's like 20 people
are you gonna make a living why
pentatonix is five penta oh
okay that's a lot hey we could have
mitch and scott teach us how to
teach it and we could perform they sold
out the hollywood three nights he's not
even part of pentatonic no he is
not obviously not loser he's jewish
though he was the jewish member of the
band
yeah well they cut him out not surprised
more [ __ ]
racial inequality um
yeah but if you're serious i have a
whole list of ideas if we want to ever
do like on the field stuff we did the
goat yoga i guess that wasn't a big hit
but
i think we should go to hollywood stand
on the corner and do doo [ __ ]
acapella or do up it's the same it's
really not there's very different oh my
god
do up is like mr salmon yes bring me a
dream daddy
make him look cute yeah i know my [ __ ]
so that's true that's both
it's both it's a mute it's a it's a
mouth
it's vocal [ __ ] no acapella's
harmonizing and
like making the beats like that and
acapella is not
doo-wop is not like base it's not doing
the instruments it's not doing that like
like uh do you know what you're talking
about
do you know what you're talking about
you need like a base you need like a bee
up has instruments
no acapella does with your mouth
can someone fact check this he doesn't
care acapella is not a genre it just
means without instruments it means
just doing music with your voice alone
but there is a
distinction between do up and acapella i
think dan just
should we get them on the show he loves
front of me and i talked i talked to him
the other day who the
the jew no the the other one
from the group the one that's like still
in it and kicking it and killing it
i have a bunch of um topics one day that
we could do like pod but i can't find
them i have so many notes
well let's let's let's we have let's get
to the i don't want to
get distracted because i want to do the
trivia yeah we need to and we got to
make this sandwich
we've got the sandwich no no hash browns
today though no tater tots
i can't i can't after last week honestly
ruined my whole [ __ ]
anyway we'll make this god what is that
that was me i'm sorry yeah
right yeah i'm sorry so do you want me
to make yours
before can you make mine because your
this is your specialty trisha wanted to
make
grilled cheese and peanut butter
sandwich
the best way to eat is like you eat and
you just go away from like
however some would argue if you want
asmr eating zach troy does uh
yeah i don't want asmr eating i'm
horrified and disgusting
i was watching back our last episode
where i was munching on tater tots the
whole time
and ela was like she was getting mad at
me
she's like ethan you keep chewing i
can't watch this
i was like i'm so sorry
because they're supposed to be my
handlers because i wasn't telling them
to stop
so today i'm going to tell you to stop
every time you start doing well i need
help
with certain things you know it's it's
everyone's responsibility right like
to remember certain things so i'll get
you because it's it's too much for one
person generally speaking
this cheese was already open did you
already eat this do you want one or two
slices on yours
what you're the you're the chef so
anyway before we get into the the pop
culture
trivia do you want to talk about um
my instagram never came back deleted
forever no not that
not that not that the [ __ ] the whole
shane stuff because
a lot developed since last you were on
yeah but you kind of like
your your hd live is like the after show
for frenemies that's why i watch it i'm
always like oh okay i just keep falling
off yeah i mean
there was there was just so much to talk
about i mean honestly
there's nothing much to talk about
rylan's a little weasel they they're
gonna get away with this [ __ ] they're
gonna glaze over it because they're rich
and they'll keep being successful and
um they lied rylan's a weasel he lied no
one cares about your podcast that's only
wake up views turn off the comments
silence your viewers no one like that
it's gonna go down your podcast will be
over
can i make a comment on his podcast it's
called the sip it's like could you try a
little [ __ ] harder
the sip it's like it's like there's so
many variations of tea
styled podcasts and shows the ship the
tea
the the steam the steam
the i've never heard the sip though like
sorry dude that's just not
cutting it we gotta the zip and also
he's just like i love that the sip is
all about drama and he's like i hate
drama and also this is not [ __ ] drama
this is something i told you guys as a
friend that like affected me i didn't
hear any drama i don't hey jeffrey i
didn't hate you guys you guys just
started becoming mean and then all this
other [ __ ] by the way i didn't even tell
you this like all this other [ __ ] well
probably it doesn't matter who cares but
i got i started getting voice memos from
people over the years of
[ __ ] talking me like his actual audio i
didn't put it out there because i
thought it was kind of weird
but recap what he said and he basically
like
heard from shane's this is the first
time i heard it because like peter man
said that he called me associate oh he
called me a sociopath
which what like you're right i saw that
video no everyone's a sociopath shane
just cause you had a fake ass therapist
on your series that was
whatever that guy sounds like he's a
sociopath if anyone is like for
and also he called me a pathological
iron associate path to peter mom because
peter mom's like oh yeah tricia said she
wants to hang out and he's like well
she's a biological liar like
i have nothing to do it's like i said oh
shane's like this and he also like
nothing prompted him to
talk [ __ ] behind you is she he wasn't
like can i trust her
she's like oh i'm hanging out with her
he's like oh cool i love her she's one
of my best friends y'all have a good
time he's like no
she's a pathological liar that was it's
like sorry
and i hung out with peter mon after that
so clearly i wasn't a pathological liar
because i did want to hang out with him
it was insane to me like that to me was
the scariest thing like you expected
from jeffrey jeffrey once again
is going to get off the hook with this
because he's a mean girl he's known for
that that's his mo i think he kind of
likes it
shane however is a little too faced
snake rylan is also a little two-faced
snake and
i don't you know i honestly would rather
be best friends with jeffrey than have
to see them ever
well at least you know what to expect
with jeffrey that's what i'm saying
because like you said he's just
he's just a douche that's just one his
defining characteristic as a human being
i get it hey i mean i get that i respect
it more you know
i should have known because everyone has
these issues with them i should have
known but shane they
the so-called uh what is it yeah the
empath this [ __ ] cracks me
no one can call you can't call yourself
an empath that's like saying i'm a good
person like you you just you can't just
say that you're obviously not if you
have to say that you are it's like
people call those rich like if you don't
call yourselves rich you're not rich
you're clearly not an empath by saying
that
no so anyway honestly don't care
honestly i'm so
over it like don't disable your comments
your [ __ ] coward like
okay so wait let me give it time imagine
if we disabled comments on frenemies
oh no what's the point i've been [ __ ] on
i've been through drama i've been
through the ringer
disabling comments and likes is like the
one thing you don't do
because it's like yeah it's so is it's
like dude you are such a [ __ ]
it's like holy [ __ ] you gotta just own
it bruh
oh god because the whole thing on the
his thing too like addressing it was
that like
i'm sorry trish can't express herself to
us [ __ ] wouldn't have ever had a
problem expressing myself to anyone i'm
expressing myself right now
like i did to you you're a little wheezy
she oh if anything she overexpressed
that's what i'm saying she's the world's
fastest talker
you know what i mean she got words per
minute she sprecks her ass into the
[ __ ]
i'm shocked but honestly i'm in shock
i'm just in shock by it honestly like
don't give a [ __ ]
so can i let's show the people what
you're doing show me the butter
so what is that process this is this is
hard to spread so is that going down on
the grill
or is that on the inside okay you got to
grease it up yeah yeah i'm just making
sure i just want to know what's going on
it's kind of hard to spread because you
should
use it i can't believe it's not butter
um fabio in a music video can somebody
plug in our
our george foreman i once had fabio in a
music video and he said every time
someone says i can't believe it's on
butter he tells me he gets like thirty
thousand dollars i don't think that's
why
that's fabio's line remember he did all
those commercials i can't believe it's
not butter
and so he told me we did a music video
on maui together like a year ago and he
was just like
every time someone says that you have to
pay me 30 000 so i just said it twice so
i guess we owe him 60
000. yeah i'm not paying you [ __ ] bob
you'll come for me that might be true
it's not true nothing i can't believe
it's not butter
fabio come get me 90 000.
i'm gonna go bankrupt saying i can't
believe it's not better so anyway let me
let me give it time and thank you for
not using their name in the title
although i did see that h3 live you guys
used jane's name
but that but that doesn't include you
what did i say oh he said shane exposed
himself or something
so many shane ones was like okay i mean
it's right whatever i don't care i
literally i figured because you weren't
in it it was fine because i was
respecting you but we're still now i'm
part of the
h3o the extended universe
yes dan yes we really did um
yeah that's how we do it around here
shane exposed it yeah
and i don't mean and and what's what's
interesting is
what you guys didn't hear is that he he
actually exposed himself to children
no i'm kidding he didn't do that oh like
but hey guess what they lie they're just
live
no one's getting in trouble okay
okay let me give the timeline so rylan
addressed trisha on this podcast
he said he was confused and taken aback
we haven't watched this together let's
watch it
oh my god this is why you're cooking so
let's watch all these draw
these vid not drama videos let's watch
these weasel
mother these sick sadists
no this is drama look how happy he is
that brian's like someone's actually
talking about me
what am i doing i'm like a [ __ ] yeah
oh my god weirdo no it's like your bread
has tourettes
it's kind of funny my bread has
tourette's can you want to explain what
that means that's like your physical
that's like the breads and version of
your hand you know when you have your
tourette's
cause you were doing that right this is
what i look like as a human being
according to trisha
just crumbs eviscerated it's fun though
like it's fun when you like knowing that
we're like cool and friends like it's
fun to have someone like tourette's just
like moses is like my middle eastern
you're my tourettes you like having
tokens around yeah but i'm like a token
like
mental case i'm the token person like
you know there's like a lot of token
things about me
right so i've never been a token i'm a
token jew i mean so is
so is there's too many of those now i
have too many tokens yeah i mean la's
token jew you got you basically
you i don't i never had a friend of
tourette's though so i do think it's
kind of cool because it's like fun we
can make chat jokes about the bread and
stuff
i mean you're making all the jokes and
i'm not sure they even make sense but
i don't take offense oh is it offensive
no i don't take it but would people take
offense to that if it wasn't you i don't
think some mate
i think it's cute i think it's a cute
thing when i watched your hp live i was
like oh i know what this is it's
tourette's
right i like being table identify things
like this non-binary thing that i am now
you know when i thought i was like
transgender like i'm like
like full full like what is the word
they say no cap no cap i
love that there's non-binary out there i
don't know that was a thing you
non-binary means you can like switch
genders you can be two genders
genders oh should we let's put this in
anyways i love this new woke world
where we have labels on things i need to
know what i am and i like it
we need to identify them so that we can
joke on them yeah it's just heating up
okay okay let's watch rylan the weasel
he looks like a weasel a little bit
sorry whatever you look like a weasel
and nobody likes you
okay wow chris's friendship means more
to me than
can you pause that ttt he canceled the
he erased the first episode of the sip
because the first episode is all about
how he wasn't friends with lizzie his
co-host
because she was with friends with
someone that was mean that he didn't
like that he thought was talking about
oh and she said friends
yeah he's like i didn't want to stay
friends with you so for four years we
didn't talk because you stayed friends
with this person
and then fast forward he's like i'm
friends with jeffrey
and trish can you see the smoke on the
camera okay here i can i'm ready
i think it's fine i think maybe there's
just some yeah that's all right it just
needs some
here i'm i'm already putting it in let
me put some peanut butter on it now it
doesn't smell like smell i think it's
just like steamed
i think it's okay here i'm gonna put the
peanut butter and we're ready to go
okay oh okay sorry okay so anyway
let's watch so yeah let's watch the
weasel st
a headlining story on this podcast i
hate that we're
a podcast that does hot topics and i've
somehow i would think because
i was saying live by the sword die by
the sword [ __ ] you
that's the how the game works trust me
you can't just sit there on the sideline
and just
laugh at everybody i mean [ __ ] now
you're in it and you did now that you're
in it you disable the comments and likes
i mean dude
own your [ __ ] that's when the tea gets
too hot and he he's like that girl at
mcdonald's who spilled all over himself
and got third degree burns you remember
that
no where was that also put the peanut
butter on the other side of the butter
bread so when people who didn't know
about peanut butter grilled cheese
it's a lot of peanut butter do this he
would put it on the other side of the
bread
yeah you see how he died oh he had a
heart attack home i'll definitely have a
heart attack that's how i'm gonna die
screenshot this when i'm like dead you
can be like see she predicted her own
death
it'll definitely be a heart attack i can
feel it well heart attacks
is kind of easy to like prophesize
because you're like i'm just going to
eat you
you're like okay i'm going to have a
heart attack so you could definitely try
to make that happen yeah i'm going to
start owning a korean fried cheese place
yeah
so far you're it's gonna happen yeah
yeah god bless
i mean hey we all gotta die right okay
so anyway do we have a flipper actually
we have to flip it right or you just
pick it up with your hands
we need a little we need a spatula can
you grab one
great so anyway the guy has the balls to
complain
he's doing a tea channel and when he
spills the tea on himself and gets
burned
he goes and cries grow up topic that i
feel i have to address in some sort of
way because i've seen i've been flooded
on
all you really thinks all elements of
social media really really
see this situation yeah also who care i
mean with peace and love ryland we want
to know what the [ __ ]
shane thinks like the sip host of this
sip
am i going too hard not at all this is
like comical i'm just like this was to
me as it's like
are you like are you an idiot like this
we want to know what shane thinks this
makes me like
jay and jeffrey just be like this is
nothing like what the hell like you're
so yeah
also apparently shane is sitting in the
room while they film yeah he always says
i was on the sip i was a guest on the
hip and he just sits in there thank you
baby it's kind of odd
thank you it's kind of weird it's a
disembodied hand just putting
yeah i mean he also edits but he knows i
mean they're like a duo
he probably that's what i'm saying so
ryland's out there like talking and then
acting like shane isn't there like we
want to know what shane thinks ryan i
mean with peace and love i mean what the
[ __ ] who are you
trish is
um mad at us right now and i guess the
only
i'm i'm confused i was taken back no no
no a little bit
and i understand like she's had drama
with jeffrey
and hair by jay who has hair by j
obviously said horrific things that i
don't stand by i don't support
obviously i support trisha over here by
jayla okay so notice
this is a really illuminating comment i
support trisha
over here by jay not jeffrey
he doesn't support jeffrey like of
course you support trisha over here by
jay you just said you don't even know
him
when he knows that it's all jeffrey said
yeah the whole the whole issue is
jeffrey
yeah it's like wow bold stance to make
dumbass followed this man i don't know
this man i've met him
once in passing yeah i met him once in
passing
so yes i support trisha over him but my
whole issue had nothing to even do with
jam just like oh he confirmed what
jeffrey was saying yes
like it wasn't even who care and before
the record and jay even said this for
the record
jay didn't say anything bad in my face
in vegas it was all and i told him
geoffrey throughout my blondes yaga yeah
yeah yeah
the thing off my hand so he's like i
don't wear things to her with jay he's
repeating
it's like it honestly like the fact that
i'm so heavily involved with this really
does break my heart
because i love trisha so much yeah i
consider her one of
my closest friends we see her more than
i see
really anyone beside you because you
come over weekly for this podcast and
yeah
i guess at the end of the day i truly no
oh you don't need to wish she would have
come to me as a
friend by the way by the way rylan this
is how much we care about you
i'd rather grill a sandwich on the
[ __ ] panini press then listen to your
ass drone on and on about
you know what i mean [ __ ] you dude you
didn't know this is closed so it cooks
it at the same time
yes that's what a panini press is no yes
i thought i had a football you're blown
away by this technology
i know to buy you this i'm gonna buy you
a wedding gift a bedazzled george
foreman grill
our realtor already gave us one not
bedazzled okay
we'll give you our realtor for our
housewarming gift he got us a panini
i'm sorry that's a little bit of a
ghetto gift for a [ __ ] new
like millions of dollar house like what
it's a panini press like 20 bucks
well it was a bougie one how long does
this take it's really fast
so it's done no it's not done i'll let
you know i'm sorry
what i feel like you've got because his
commission he made hundreds of thousand
dollars from that commission you don't
buy piniti press that's what you buy for
like
a [ __ ] wedding for somebody you don't
care about you said you were getting
well i was kidding i was kidding
i wouldn't actually buy you that i mean
we actually don't want presents for our
wedding
we have enough nobody needs to you could
donate to something maybe the transit
quality to the human fund
reference nobody likes seinfeld he's my
least favorite
uh literally okay i'm not going to get
into that i
i can't i'm just going to forget you
said that
i'm just going to excuse me are you
seriously going to talk [ __ ] about
anyone's stereotyping jewish people
jewish people are like a fetish to you
is it done what do you think the butter
is like what oh
god okay but even curb like i can't
watch because it's just like a little
too much first of all curb has nothing
to do with seinfeld okay
right yes but we're talking about
i don't like it i can't i just go back
here before anyone calls me anti-semitic
i don't like friends either i just don't
like any of those shows in new york i
don't like new yorkers no offense
okay i can't we're moving on
um what were we talking about whatever
so let's let's just send this dumbass uh
roll on this really does break my heart
because i love trisha so much
i know i love anything consider her one
of my closest friends we see her
more than i see really anyone besides
you because you come over weekly for
this podcast and
i guess at the end of the day i truly
wish she would have come to me as a
friend if she was hurting like
the way that she is every time they hung
out with me
my birthday shane's birthday all
throughout the summer when shane was
getting canceled they came to house and
all i kept saying
is how jeffrey sucked and how i'm so
[ __ ] up
like upset by like how are you guys
still friends but i i didn't even judge
them for being friends it's like okay
they need to get the coin or whatever
because they're not gonna make videos
anymore and i was like i wasn't even
judging
but like the fact that he's like she
should have come to us and then when
shane texted me about it i came to him
and he's like well let's just forget it
happen
let's just i don't believe you what the
[ __ ] do you want from me yeah it's like
well obviously when you told them they
didn't take it seriously which
is completely evident by the fact that
he says here we're friends with both of
them
and they're having a drama so it's like
what what exactly did you expect her to
tell you
you know and for the record ryland was
like oh yeah jeffrey is mean to me and
morgan she doesn't give a [ __ ] about us
like
she or he only likes shane and like it's
true like jeffrey just likes the people
well to be honest who likes rylan
no comment honestly it took me a minute
i like being a [ __ ] now to them
i mean for the ragged i really didn't
talk to him that much i talked to him i
talked to
shane so what did he do if you're
visiting the house what does roiland do
he's very quiet which i don't judge i
mean
they asked me last year like this is
insane to me this is
insane this and then obviously all the
spiral of him talking [ __ ] about me
throughout the years
it's insane i've never once said
anything bad about shane and i like
blind like
and the reason i'm so vocal about this
sounds like get over whatever the reason
i'm so vocal about it is because i was
so vocal for him
being like shane's a good person all
this no shane's like a piece of [ __ ]
person and like i don't know any of this
stuff because i didn't i blindly
defended him so i don't know like these
other things that were happening
but honestly he's like a [ __ ] person so
i just have to reiterate i do not defend
him
i do not stand by him he's an actual
[ __ ] person i take back everything i've
ever said because i thought it was a
different person than i knew like he
this is a different person
so maybe he is has he not tried to
reconcile and he locked him on
everything so oh
which is good respect my boundaries
don't contact me
thinking i think it should be more brown
i like it buttery you don't okay i'll
take however you like it
oh my god you're playing with the crust
i know it's disgusting i'm a [ __ ]
psycho
so as you're scooping i'll i'll keep
bling wouldn't have played out on the
internet like this
i just am really
honestly confused because i see her all
of the time and
even after the last time jeffrey was
physically on this podcast
i was at her house and we had a
wonderful loving time and i understand
maybe
it's hard for her to express
her actual feelings towards jeffrey to
us or the gravity in which she's
feeling feelings towards jeffrey
um it's super condescending the whole
thing
i wish you would have told me she has a
hard time expressing herself it's like
shut up dude
i was literally like gonna let it go
until i saw this and i was like this is
someone who's supposedly my best friend
stuff like that
like he knows all this stuff like he's
so fake the fakeness is like insane to
me
they're literally doing everything they
can to not condemn jeffrey
to get that paycheck but guess what
conspiracy palettes on sale everything
that shane has on jeffree's site was up
50
off now so obviously they're trying to
cut ties or something they bought too
much [ __ ]
that's what happened oh my god he knows
we're
specifically friendly with jeffrey so
maybe it's hard for her to like
ask me to cut him off but at the same
time i do
it's like what are you what am i gonna
say don't be friends with him yeah
it's so crazy but me i freaking if they
don't like someone i
blindly cut that person out of my life
i'm just like yeah those people are
[ __ ] too they're out of my life too
like
but they know in so much detail and then
they also shane saying i'm scared of
jeffrey ryland saying yeah jeffrey's not
nice
and then like i'm just in shock but not
only did they they didn't have to throw
jeffrey under the bus to defend me you
know what i'm saying like they the fact
that he's like
putting it all on me the blame on me
being like well trisha didn't come to us
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah he didn't see him
going down no one [ __ ] cares you were
irrelevant before now you're really
irrelevant now
shane's talented rylan is just marrying
someone who's talented
okay don't you how do you feel it's not
melted off no it's good this looks
melted
verdicts out whoa
is that right well i will say i don't
like how it pressed down
i think the flip would have been better
oh the press because yeah
but it's good you just can't taste them
it flattened it too much
do you like it with peanut butter though
i'm processing i don't think so with a
little bit of the texture you don't like
it
well you have two bites so you didn't
hate it or you're just like trying i'm
gonna give it a fair chance
i'm out no
it's like warm and like gooey i don't
like the
the cheese and the peanut butter is not
it really not it
elvis would turn over in his grave it's
one of his favorite meals who elvis
i mean he would fry it what do i gotta
like everything elvis likes i mean he's
kind of cool do you not like elvis are
you not an elvis fan
i'm actually not i don't like elvis i
don't like anything about elvis i don't
like his music
i don't like his whole [ __ ] attitude
and i certainly don't like the food he
likes let me guess you're a beatles fan
huge beatles fan i think they suck
they're literally the four dancing
elvises that's all
well i feel like you if you say the
beatles suck you
you objectively have bad taste i don't
like their attitude i don't like that
they think they're they're better than
god i don't like that they don't believe
in god you're talking about john lennon
how about all the beatles well i think
john lennon is the only one that said
that they're bigger than god
they'll corroborate with it i don't like
to be honest they kind of are bigger
than god
i think god is the biggest
okay name one song he's made everything
everything the beatles made
that's god um nice
exactly thank you oh i love when i win
well that that means he made
well if god made every music then that
means he made um
creed oh so
question his question is creed i think
creed i think creed is one of those
bands that's this cool you like it i'm
just fat
i'm honestly just that that's so not
true because i'm bad enough i don't like
something i won't eat it that's not me i
didn't i mean
no that's not true okay let's watch this
you gotta like just i don't wanna keep
biting this is the eating part
let's get it out of the way much better
that time
yep i think you had it too hot so you
weren't tasting it properly
[Music]
so anyway when everyone started uh
smashing on him
he disabled likes and comments like a
little [ __ ] that's crazy
you're a drama channel bro you can't do
that
it's insane here's an example of some of
the comments that he was uh erasing
let's see they were saying i wish you
would have come to me personally about
it
as a friend seeing someone literally
break down in tears after disgusting
monster picks her apart with such hatred
online
why didn't you think to ask if she's
okay boom head shot
the fact that lizzy gave a better
apology than either shane or ryland
speaks volumes to people
she she looks in the camera and she's
giving like and also i don't really know
i met her one time i don't know anything
about her i have nothing against her but
she's
in the camera getting apology and then
right after she was like all right wow
yeah i saw that
she was like you know what i'm sorry we
had jeffrey on because he didn't say
that i didn't get that part oh she
actually was really nice she's like
i'm really sorry we had jeffrey on and
that we did something to hurt
trisha's feelings because i really like
her and i feel like
i feel very regretful and then he goes
okay
moving on you know what's crazy yeah
what's crazy i'm going to say this one
more time to reiterate and drive it home
like jeffree star has tried to apologize
to me like a couple times throughout the
past year right i don't accept it
because i heard you continue talk [ __ ]
but
but regardless he did try to apologize
which is more than rylan
or shane they never apologized they were
always like well i wish he would have
come to us i wish he would never once
said
i'm so sorry always it's insane it's
so insane even here by jay this like
crazy ass person was like texting me was
like hey
i apologize like so jeffrey apologized
like last year like for a couple months
here by jay apologize
shane and rylan nope the empaths
uh girl you should have talked to us
before you took it online
it's i apologize to shane for things
that i didn't even do
i might apologize like it's insane so
you announced you're taking a break from
social media how long did that take
oh i really did want to but here's the
thing people you said here
i blame you actually really um and
yeah i am actually gonna probably take a
break for like i don't know like a week
and i'm taking a week off from posting
on youtube and probably just any social
medias so
um i think you posted an hour after that
announcement
i think it was like a day a day i
believe how was your break no
you know why i wasn't going to be online
i wasn't emailing guess what who get i
get a whatsapp from somebody and guess
who that whatsapp is from
ethan saying did you see this and then i
go the [ __ ] off because you're
the one who sends me you got to know
what's going on no i said tick tock hey
just don't send me anything anybody and
then three hours later i'm not
i'm not i'm not getting my messages from
tick tock
well apparently you are there's my tick
tock right there dude you post like 100
tick tocks a day anyone that watches
every single one
needs a [ __ ] life with peace and
loves it's way too much for any person
to consume maybe you need to watch it
james charles
in the biggest twist of the century
he says it's so liberating when people
finally start to see what you've been
seeing all along
and i said holy [ __ ] is this a turned
into a pro james
anti-shane podcast for pro james
yeah [ __ ] them all let god sort them out
remember when i was talking [ __ ] about
james when he did the tutti frutti she
stole your tie first time
when that was all happening shane was
talking to me and he'd come over and be
like did you know
he also stole this makeup look from a
palette so then when i came in front of
me i was all fired up i was like yeah
you know what he also stole this makeup
book
i couldn't give a [ __ ] about james
charles for all this like i didn't know
anything about him but he ingrained it
in my head that this guy was like awful
i'm like yeah let's go
that's like that's what i do like you
heard like what did you say unless
you're like if you heard one of my
friends and i'm [ __ ] coming for you
too you know what i mean
mm-hmm i didn't care about james at all
and i was just like he was like using
you oh for sure
even when i was mad at david he'd always
be like oh like david's a sociopath did
you hear this clip from this audio but
like obviously i'm not gonna bring it up
cause i don't give a [ __ ] but i was just
like what a weird
anyways whatever you let's do trivia he
liked to trigger me but yeah oh yeah oh
honey
we love honey join honey.com these days
it feels like online shopping is the
only shopping we really do can i get a
amen amen that's all you can do i'm not
going i'm not going in store were you
crazy
but it's better that you do it online
because you've got honey
who's today's sponsors and if you love
frenemies
then please use honey to help support
the show it's a free browser extension
that scours
the internet for promo codes and
automatically tests them
when you're checking out this is what
i'm saying you can be lazy about it you
don't have to search for i don't use
coupons not because like i'm like baller
it's just because i'm lazy
you know honey dude i used to get so
like
neurotic about like if you're buying
something expensive you're like cuz you
could save hundreds of dollars with the
right cookies yeah you could
eat i'm like come on like where's the
coupon honey does all that for you
that's pretty dope and sometimes they
find like the really deep cuts like
sometimes honey [ __ ] us up on teddy
fresh because
they find like deep cut coupons that we
make for individual customers oh really
and we're like what the [ __ ] how are
people getting these coupon codes
honey i'm telling you all right at least
they're sponsoring us so you're kind of
getting some money back
yeah well i i go okay i got i like
disable the codes because i was like
honey's too good
okay a little insider information yeah
yeah anyway
here's how it works you get honey on
your computer for free and two easy
clicks
then when you're checking out to when
then when you're checking out on one of
its over 30 000 supported sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply coupon
yeah it just pops up so you don't search
for the codes on instagram or anything
when you're at the cart when you're
checking out it goes hold on honey is
tapping into the forest
[Laughter]
and then like one code available you
just save 50 bucks or whatever
that's pretty cool and then you just
click apply
it only takes a few seconds honey finds
working codes and applies the best one
to the car
immediately bada boom body bam forget
about it i seriously
save like ila shops online she's
she shops a lot yeah she's always every
week it's like 50 bucks 100 bucks it's
crazy
saving or spending saving oh spend okay
oh my god she's really spending it yeah
she's been big i don't know who's been
not even close i feel like you guys are
more fancy with what you spend no
she buys regular [ __ ] she'll buy like a
pair of levi's or something but you're
buying like
burqas that's like a whole different
stratosphere could buy honey
no probably not yeah but i don't think
any i mean i don't know how many of our
audience members are in the market for
that right
yeah okay join honey join honey but you
gotta but you sign up all you have to do
is sign up one time with joint.com other
sites you have to go through their site
and shop but you have to go through
there and then go
no like you just do join honey.com yeah
it's just the extension
joanhoney.com frenemies it's takes two
clicks you add it it's an extension and
then you're done forever you're set for
life
honey has listen to this honey has saved
its 17 million members over two billion
dollars
and that's pretty dope honey supports
all kinds of retailers from tech gaming
sites fashion browns and eve
brands and even food delivery it's so
simple if you have a computer
honey should be on it it's free and
works with whatever browser you use you
can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
frenemies that's join honey.com
frenemies so they know we sent you
thanks honey for supporting today's
episode oh my god our first like
frenemies code yeah this is cool that's
great i'm very
happy i think that means the show's
working yeah
because adam and eve is like well
they're weird because adam and eve is
for like
a lot of people are like oh trish is
there like we got you when
i was leaving well anyways that's all
the pronunciation there's a sponsorship
of them right here because they're not
oh
speaking of sponsors what whatever
happened with fashion nova
i got sponsored i have a six month
contract with them not no mentions on
the podcast though they did they did say
they cut that part out
because they saw the episode that's so
funny so but they didn't say i just
they like that conversation even though
i was [ __ ] on them yeah they're like
if you want to go through the podcast in
the future and i was like i don't know
if they were being serious or not i was
like i can't hook you up i don't know
like either look if you pay me
i'll be out i'll be out here and all
this skinny jeans and [ __ ] they sell
you know i wonder if that was like a
thing though if that was like a test and
i passed it they baited you
i mean i do shop from them for real for
real like anyone could attest that like
like we opened packages always some
fashion overview i don't support uh
right
teddy fresh is only website that i
personally shop from and they think that
you shop from snapboard2005.com
yeah this is exception yeah we got some
cool stuff coming out so whatever
we got some cool design stuff but like
it's all right let's do trivia um also
okay
yeah well i'm just gonna say something
ah it doesn't matter i can't remember
i'm ready
this is pretty good i think i prefer
without the peanut butter though
that's just a grilled cheese yeah trish
grilled cheese
i thought the elvis grilled cheese well
i was like the bananas with the peanut
butter too we could put bananas on it
and then it becomes more elvis and he
fries it
that's disgusting i love it fried
okay let's play i'm so excited what are
we playing for
um a thousand bucks
this is stupid though cause you're
definitely gonna win i'm basically just
giving you a thousand bucks
here let me transfer it now it's on no
we can donate it
we can donate it so who gets okay i like
the idea i'm going to donate my
transequality.org they find job
placement for trans people help get them
off the screen
against violence they're such a good
yeah so good they're so amazing i love
them
let's do i'll support them as well so
whoever went oh so wait
we're supposed to be playing for like
separate charities otherwise
[ __ ] trans rights charity my charity day
i mean no it's fine but usually like on
celebrity press everyone has their own
charity they're playing for
well i didn't really think about it but
i really like planned parenthood they
helped me in heal a lot when we were
really poor
with like uh birth control and stuff
like that so i i always thought planned
parenthood was great
and i hate that they get like it's so
[ __ ] up that like
people target them because it's just
such a great organization so maybe
planned parenthood okay we just donate
to both honestly but i think it's fun to
like i wish
i always thought it's funny i thought it
was funny in these shows how they're
like
this money goes to this charity so don't
[ __ ] up
and then they leave with zero and it's
like well it raises awareness regardless
right because i just talked about
transit
yeah but just give the money dumb these
like these shows are so cheap
here's the thing i would not know about
a lot of charities like people didn't
promote it like i didn't know about
broadway cara's equity
fight aids i didn't know all that [ __ ]
you know what i mean like it's cool it's
such a cool organization but
you have to talk about it so people can
like know what to do but if they give
the money still
oh we'll give it yeah whatever where av
where are you are we playing
can i go yeah what do you want what do
you want
nothing that's so nice of you now i'm
good what do you want nothing you said
can i get a what
you're in such a good mood today you
guys are both in good mood what you said
can i get a what
can i get a what why are you in such a
good mood i get pregnant
no we're not you guys are both like
beaming today
i don't know you always say that and i'm
not sure i ever agree no today you guys
are like
right super talkative where'd you get
that oh i'll take it okay
oh yeah sure put the money on the table
no it's right
we'll just donate it where'd you get all
the money okay okay
welcome everybody
this is like a mouthful with the peanut
butter and the cheese yeah they used to
put it on mr ed's teeth so he could talk
during the show
i was just gonna say i feel like mr ed
[Laughter]
okay
[Music]
who painted these oh by the way pull up
your sign we painted your spin
i love the branding of this show thank
you so much
shout out once again to starkiller he
loves it why do you know his channel
name
huh it pops up it kept popping up
what the hell is this and then i saw it
with him and i was like
nope because you don't watch but you
know everything
that's right watching like you know
everything about everything
no i started watching the h3 after show
because it's like it's really like a
friend of mine because we just talked
about you guys
always talk about me and i get so
excited once you stop that doesn't
explain how you know it was starkiller
though
because it kept popping up i don't buy
it no i swear i kept popping up and i
was at that like
you're more of a fan than you than you
admit he's new i wouldn't even know
i do watch now please don't make zach
the bachelor though the bachelor
no you don't think that's gonna be not
he doesn't deserve love
he's not ready for it he even said on
the show he's like he's not looking for
like love he said that might be true
on the show he's not ready for it and
you guys have such a good success rate
of like
fighting actual people i think i should
be able to pick it for people because no
offense to the h3 crew they picked some
really bad contenders
not really we had to go behind the
scenes and hook it up it doesn't matter
that's the whole point of the friend of
me it never works out how you expect
so i'll pick like ian's girl
now girlfriend they're living together
no i know he wasn't on the show either
so you guys are doing something wrong
there something's wrong but right sure
somebody plays with him just stop maybe
just stop like
going with like the crew we love the
crew on industry they're great but maybe
just something outside of that
i'm told i need to stop chewing i like
it i find it comforting to be honest
but i get you comments say it okay we're
done
we're playing the game all right
welcome everybody to pop culture trivia
today i am your host and contestant
ethan
the host i'm your contestant ethan
with my co-contestant trish who's our
host
i'll be your host i guess yeah yeah ab
starkiller
okay first question list the four
beetles
are you serious did you just come up
with this one right now why this is good
no i think this is good because i can
still look this way right because
there's no answers over not that i can
see anything
i got on my phone thank god oh my god
um you might actually get this wrong oh
are you kidding me
i'm not an idiot
what was the exact word of the question
list the four beatles
i just have to go with semantics you
know what i mean there's not much
semantics just list the name
well there's there's a very specific
yeah okay are you going with the four
original beetles or that's a good
question
the four beetles there's four beetles
that everybody knows founding members
are the
it's the four beetles no trish is right
you should get bonus points if you can
name it there's no bonus points
it's the four beatles who's the original
drummer do you know him do you
yeah okay so write a genius okay that's
not the question though dan stop giving
her bonus boys you don't even know what
you're doing you don't know who
you're not even the host who are you why
are you even commenting wow okay a
beetle stand
okay here it is ready are ready
ringo john paul george pete best
trisha had more do you have more info
it's not that question
i mean that is the four beatles if you
want to go with the original beatles
it's pete best
we both got it what am i who's the host
somebody take control of this situation
and it's definitely not dan dan i should
listen more but the question was list
the four beetles the four beatles
okay but technically ringo is an
additional member he wasn't the original
beatle but whatever okay
literally everybody knows what the
question is asking
okay question number two who is the
supporting actor and kim kardashian sex
sex tape kim k superstar was that the
name of it
i didn't know that i think i know it but
i'm not sure
they had a title for it i guess so yeah
even wrote the questions but
did they sell it oh they sold it i
thought it was like supposedly like i
thought it was leaked as well yeah
damn i thought kim's mom leaked it
all right you know what off the rails
let's just say it right there ready go
did i get it right ray j yep good
correct he used to sponsor my podcast
raycon who's keeping um
who's keeping track moses okay good mo i
trust moses
dan i don't trust dan just here to
humiliate me
[Music]
okay and it was sold by vivid
entertainment so i was right on that one
again
what wow wow
okay what is the name of the song used
in the infamous
rick roll meme online
where's the motown questions temptations
what is that his song huh
rick roll huh number
no i don't know phil spector died he
dated somebody from motown remember
one of the raw nets he just died in
prison where is he
ready say the question again tristan's
confused the hell out of me why is he
talking about motown
what is the name of the song used in the
infamous
yeah oh wait i think i got wait hold on
i i did the wrong thing
wait hold on i don't gotta be serious
about this
so no one has points or we're just tied
um i've never lost in pop culture
trivia just fyi okay i got it
alfredo is better for the record
everybody he's perfectly fine
okay ready never gonna give you up
what'd you put that's not that you put
it down
you have to show it dopey i just wrote
strangers to love
strangers because that's like whatever
it is yeah
okay never gonna give you up yeah [ __ ]
i'm such an idiot
i should have thought about that more um
that's good
good though i mean he's got like a
lyrics
the reason that's so good is just
because he's like this little dude with
this extremely deep voice it's chocolate
rain vibes
for sure hungarian vibes yeah dangerous
chocolate rain vibes for sure i thought
it was literally the same person because
that voice
how did i get that wrong next moving on
drake rose to fame as an actor on which
tv show
see i didn't watch all that disney [ __ ]
either not disney i know he was in a
wheelchair
okay well that's good so you know he was
in uh the sweet life
i'm kidding i don't think i'm just gonna
take a stab i don't know i miss
like i never want was disney a premium
channel because i never watched that
no definitely not we had it because my
dad was a cheap [ __ ] and he wouldn't
spend on anything you guys didn't have
like what channel was it on
it wasn't nickelodeon or disney it
wasn't a premium channel because it's a
canadian show so it's like one of those
weird was it a popular show
it might have re-ran on nickelodeon pbs
yeah something weird pbs
who the [ __ ] watches pbs no i don't
think it was
a tvs no not tvs i don't know well
that's even worse anyways do you know
the answer
jake and josh no
um
i don't i have no [ __ ] clue
degrassi
yeah what the hell is degrassi smoke
degrassi
okay particularly the next generation
oh no point for trisha what is this star
trek
how many generations does the grassy
need
the civilization of the future say by
the bell how like the college years the
new
all right next i'm losing i'm not happy
trisha is leading by two
yes i know ab which which sports figure
met with kim jong-un
say what which sports figure met with
kim jong-un oh i know that
my bff dude why do you know all this you
should not know at least one of these
i was on his podcast why i have no idea
i never aired either and it was such a
good podcast like
okay i'm ready your boy dennis rodman
correct our only hope to peace in uh
southeast asia he's mr peace and love
isn't that his thing i think he
yeah no that's ringo's peace and love
oh i'm thinking dennis roth met a world
peace
i get them confused peace and love okay
moving on name as many disney movies
released in the 90s as you can see
why are you going to do this why are you
going to do name as many we'll be here
what the hell yeah what why am i a
disney freak
who says i'm a disney freak all the time
i just because i go like disneyland
doesn't mean i know what disney's
right oh god you're gonna win why am i
gonna waste the effort in my arm i'm
kidding me be a good sport
i'm angry i know perpetually
and everyone's making fun of my spelling
like when i wrote the
the kardashians i misspelled all their
names
well that sounds like a you issue
yes sure should thank you we watched a
disney movie like every night me and
moe's
we watched so many of these holy cow
okay so i don't know which ones are from
the 90s or which ones are from like
before that
oh you we grew up in the 90s you
shouldn't yeah tried i picked 90s
to go easier on here right but maybe
that made it harder
good ones best ones
i like the show where we just sit and
silently right for 10 minutes because
there's so many of them
um we should have a timer
yeah too i mean you're kind of going in
let me see
oh yeah uh what was that one called um
oh
maybe i should be like one of those
sports commentators ethan looks
determined
he's trying to figure it out he's
thinking back to his childhood well what
is trisha currently
the tiger oh i know i know maybe you
have a total amount of movies
don't give her a number how dare you i
thought that's what we want to know
yeah no just name as much as you can oh
but we don't want to give you the photo
okay god i gotta go yeah
cuz i mean i mean i guess i could like
really deep bit dive in like i'm trying
to like
dive in
the 90s ethan's concentrating very hard
in the 90s brad
going back to his childhood thinking of
all the [ __ ] 90s
the 90s trish rugrats
i wrote rugrats disney that's
nickelodeon it's not even a movie i know
it's a joke
i didn't come out with regards to movie
okay
right you're right okay rugrats the
movie here rugrats semicolon
that doesn't count um there's got to be
more hold on
hold the [ __ ] phone i'm imagining all
the prints there wasn't much princesses
in the 90 was there
that wasn't a princess decade hmm
okay we need some princess decades
heroines heroes hold on let me scan oh i
just thought of a good one
yes yes yes i got one i think i wouldn't
need one more
tricia i have one two three four
five six
how many do you have seven see that's
not okay we're gonna be here all day
just write something else down
i mean i'm gonna be here all day because
you guys didn't put a timer
time i mean that's what i'm saying are
we talking about
all disney movies or specifically like
cartoons
no direct
all right i added shazam and schindler's
list and mechanically they said cartoons
but okay
not that i'm saying those aren't quite
so many read them off ethan 101
dalmatians
okay not from the 90s aladdin
rugrats no nickelodeon doug
nickelodeon i'm stupid i love dog though
little mermaid
uh i think unfortunately that one was
from 1989.
oh and then i just barely missed it that
is beauty and the beast
oh i forgot mulan beasts long counts
hercules
hercules that's on it yeah shazam nope
nope schindler's list
unfortunately shazam's automatic saving
private ryan
so how many did you get correct four
right
three three or four beauty and the beast
mulan
aladdin hercules hercules and shazam
how do you feel beating the beast that
was good one i don't even know how
that's in my mind
so i did i already i already eliminated
a little mermaid for my list because
yeah
god your writing is hard oh lion king
what you
idiot pocahontas pocahontas hercules
mulan toy story
wait toy story's pixar doesn't count toy
story does not count i'm afraid but it's
disney
it had was pixar a picture it was it
wasn't uh disney yet
unacquired at that time yeah that one
doesn't count yeah i think you still won
what the [ __ ] does that say lady and the
[ __ ] oh that's like meg old that's not
from the 90s either when is it from so
hold on this is actually close no she's
still one
one yeah two three she got one more than
me
that's crazy lion king
well i love beauty the beast i don't
know why i put that down like i watched
at the ever like every day anyway you
went again trisha wins again
and maybe what were the ones neither of
them got um you guys did not get
the rescuers down under yeah nobody
cares
beauty and the beast right i literally
wrote that oh you got beauty and beast
the hunchback of notre dame
tarzan really doesn't really count
tarzan was like
such a black sheep it was so [ __ ] i
wanna know
all right moses okay damn we just
watched hunchback on monday night too
that movie kind of sucked though yeah
that wasn't that wasn't one of the
classics
we forget about those ones moving on
celebrity
was caught shoplifting almost six
thousand dollars worth of goods from sex
easy i think i know actually also people
always like note that we only get along
if we're like yelling at people or
eating
well then we know what we gotta do
because we like go so hard when we like
yeah
like we went we went crazy on dan last
episode
i felt bad about the rescuers and we're
like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you ap nobody likes that movie take
it off the list
okay i think i know the then i think i
know
when i want to write okay good right
correct
everybody take screenshots of all my
terrible spellings and make fun of me
i mean i don't know if i spelled it
already either i love her and mr deeds
though such a good movie okay
that's one of those things where i'm
surprised i even know it but well that
was a pretty big deal i'd be surprised
if you didn't know it
okay what was the first video
played on mtv whatever
first music video make a guess first
music video is that pop culture or like
dinosaur
bones first video first music video
famous it's pretty famous no hints
oh [ __ ]
should i get that rick roll um
just because i knew this song i knew the
that wasn't the it wasn't give us a
little bit i can't go back and litigate
i can't go back
i'm never gonna give you where is he now
rick ashley
rick astley yeah where is he is that his
name ashley and tly
astley i was like ashley i think there's
no way
we should have spelling bee i'm so good
at those i killed it in my spelling bee
every year
i'd be down to do a spelling bee you
just said you smell horrible well
there's i don't i'm not good with names
because everyone's like
right jared with a [ __ ] where the r
is spelled with a y but you could spell
like anti-disobedient absenteeism
i could probably spell that because it's
pretty very phonetic we have five
seconds on the clock
yeah come on let's go did you make
something
i'm writing three titles just to cover
my eyes okay but you have to
but i might be a song there's one
specific song so
what's the what did you what is it what
did you put i'm putting you you show me
first you don't show your answers
you tell me what's the answer
billie jean the answer is video killed
the radio star
by is it the bugles
oh yeah i want my mtv what the hell
that's actually that's the dire straight
song it's not called i want my interview
they go
i want my mtv i thought that was the
okay so you were way off i could i get
can i get some bonus points for being
closer than her dan since we were giving
out bonus points all the time willy
nilly yeah but i actually got something
right you didn't even get it right so
whatever whatever you whatever
okay moving on it's stupid what dead
musical artist
was brought to life by a hologram at
coachella in 2012
i know that one i know something you
don't pop culture
loser no i do know this no you don't
write it
say that one more time what dead musical
artist
was brought to life you heard the
question at coachella in 2012.
oh my god i hate coachella i like just
about anything has to do with it
uh it's pop culture oh oh no no no no no
no
god i hope you don't know it i need this
okay
ready i think she got it no i don't know
show me tupac
yeah you're right you got it
i should i wrote it like more street oh
he wrote like nothing but ig thing right
or not i feel like she spelled it wrong
can i get points
no bonus points for the two pack i love
tupac both answers are acceptable so sad
about him
okay what group was beyonce originally
part of god easy
i know it but just give me a second
i'll eat my grilled cheese peanut butter
sandwich
he can't go back in history it's not
[ __ ] motown your dad wasn't a pop
music you told me on the radio
actually they did a motown song they did
emotions
a lot of people do motown songs
something like sister act
sister act oh my god this direct too
uh it is perfect
i'd [ __ ] what is it
destiny child right destiny
what's the score of moses
okay who's saying the motown classic my
girl
stupid
i think i know it what did why did you
write so fast
i mean i think i might be wrong but for
up four tops
temptations temptations oh [ __ ] i knew
that
i can't even roast you because i kind of
feel bad now because you said you like
love motown and then you got a motown
question wrong so i was like oh is it
bad
temptations of course okay
what
but don't you know that like that's the
biggest roast like that's just now
you're just being mean
okay so i'll just be me next time yeah
if you're like it's too sad for me to
make fun of you that's mean
okay i'll roast you next time yeah yeah
okay what are the names of the two main
characters in the twilight series
why you asking me that ib blame ian
why you asking me that [ __ ] i mean i
never even seen twilight and i know this
we just talked about the podcast
literally
it's [ __ ] like uh uh heather
and uh jeff okay
[Laughter]
twilight series i can't even think of
single one
you're just edward and bella oh i didn't
know i didn't know that
well listen dan i don't have a
photographic memory okay oh we just
talked about it what do i just commit
everything we talk about the memory
i didn't say edward and bell i didn't
know that was their names okay
[Laughter]
and the movie back to the future i love
it
what year did marty travel back to in
the first one
1942 right before the start of the world
war ii
1940 don't you think he should have gone
back and tried to kill hitler
not everything is about hitler
you try so hard to push the ant hitler
thing on the show
of all the things you could go back and
undo don't you think world war ii is a
good one
i think there's something in the rules
like you can't undo them
what roles back to the future rules
i was at sex with someone from back of
the future can you guess who that is
don't care crisp and clever
oh wait wait what year did he travel
back to yeah yeah sorry
oh i'm way off it's back further than
that yeah yeah sorry my bad too i i i
got the right
okay wait hold on i'm going to run like
okay 19
65 58. it is 1955.
okay i knew i had 55. i knew it was a
five at the end can i get some bonus
points
can i get bonus points for getting a
five right
okay next you got it right yeah
no i don't i was like what i was trying
to okay
there were two british royal weddings
this decade name at least one of the
couples involved
i can do that yeah i mean come on
okay i love that i love the bonus point
no there's no
what do you mean bonus point okay
this is great this is really good
silently writing we'll just call this
episode silently right you're so bitter
that you're just like not getting
anything wrong
i'll voice it over yes our last one was
like that too our last one was just like
silently writing i'm gonna try
you will i like the length to be honest
people like a little silence once in a
while oh my god okay
okay okay harry and megan i got
something wrong you get the bonus points
there's no bonus point yeah there
literally is there's no you don't know
the other royal couple that got married
this decade
no i mean this the bald dude and the
chick
you don't know his name charles
no will and kate correct
i'm harry and megan harry and megan i
have harry megan on there too so okay
well whatever
one point
next what's the score don't tell me
what's the score
oh wait i just got a point i was at five
no but she only got the bonus point now
there's no
bonus point i'm gonna flip this table if
anybody
mentions bonus point again wait i i have
six now i just got one right
so she has a thirteen and you have six
because i only gave her one more not two
so yeah okay but but she didn't have any
bonus points right
you have to decide you want to vote
there's no bonus point i don't need a
bonus point wait wait wait wait wait
wait like what the [ __ ]
i take control a b you're the host
you're letting a damn
date bonus points again there's no
[ __ ] bonus points i'm the kid
baby tell him all right i'll just do it
to shut up we'll just stop trying to
help out trisha
think i know i know i know be clear
about that
dan has nothing to do with this game dan
is not involved
he's doing this oh yeah i don't know why
it does okay
the mic song it was dan it wasn't moses
just for the record i think
it doesn't have enough players okay
name at least one team from each of the
four big leagues
nba nfl mlb and nhl
just one what that so hold on so nb okay
whatever
basketball football baseball hockey one
team
i mean that's awesome okay so wait
basketball football okay football
baseball and hockey okay
i got it i actually got this one well
this couldn't be easier i could name
500 of them wow aren't you [ __ ]
special
genius well this is such easy okay
lakers dodgers rams king snacks
browns calves indians maple leaves
maple leaves toronto is that even an
american team
he didn't say american they are in the
nhl though
right what are you talking about of
course they are i'm just trying listen
i'm trying to get technicalities on you
know
okay okay they're in their own league
i think ethan might get this one oh
what was the first video ever uploaded
to youtube about
i know it ah this is your life it's just
being a nerd about youtube videos
for the record this is the only question
i wrote thank you
you're my favorite the first video ever
uploaded youtube
yeah what was it what was it about yeah
okay it was some dude at the zoo
right that's correct i said neon cat
neon cat that was like only a few years
ago oh my god you're such a nerd
i got a point i got a point can she get
can we minus a point from her score for
being so far off
oh my god next okay
score thirteen eight
how did he get two he was just at six
why are you okay
oh no no question moses
no no she's questioning your integrity
oh my god
calm down i'm kidding okay
prior to hamilton what was lynn manuel
miranda's first major musical done and
done
you seriously
you know it i think we talked about it i
think you know it for sure
can we get him on the podcast
i'm sure he's i'm sure he's not busy
yeah
he's booked looking busy
moana
did you not write anything down what
does it look like
you were writing something though i
erased it why
i know i don't know the name i don't
know what trish will finish him
in the heights oh yes correct i mean
annihilation at this point sometimes
sometimes trivia is like not fun if
someone just doesn't know anything it's
just like okay i don't know
it's not that i don't i know some stuff
damn
okay god which celebrity said the
following
the jews are responsible for all the
wars in the world
oh my god sorry which celebrity
said the following the jews are i mean i
heard you the first time but what
that's insane some celebrity yes
said the jews are responsible for all
the wars of the world
i mean i think i know i mean there's one
guy that comes to mind i thought you'd
know it
who's kind of always got the right takes
is it i don't okay okay i think it's mel
gibson the one and only i have sasha
baron cohen it is mel
gibson well i feel like he might do it
for borat or something maybe he says oh
the jewel
i don't think that's i don't think
that's a joke no mel it's my boy mel
gibson wait he said it to him yeah mel
gibson's a psycho
he's he's like a crazy anti-semite nice
to me like when i met him i met him one
time and he was couldn't have been
sweeter why do you
have stories about everybody i don't
support the anti because he's a catholic
not that i was he's also like super
racist he he famously said
you can bleep this dan and please bleep
this but just so you hear what he says
he says
he said to his ex-wife i hope you get
on the phone is it real yes he said that
he's
crazy you could just bleep the crap
out of that dude he's so [ __ ] i would
not get that vibe from him i meant him a
couple times
make sure yeah no i'm sure he's can be a
nice guy but he's a psychiatrist
total racist but he's catholic uh
so was hitler no taylor wasn't catholic
weren't they all about cat when weren't
they all about jesus god
oh equal that was communist [ __ ] that's
not true
hitler was definitely not catholic i'll
tell you that yeah he was great
they like to okay whatever who might
have just argued this point
okay what did ariana grande accidentally
tattoo on her finger in japanese
oh my god i know nothing about ariana
grande i
know nothing about that was ian he's
such a weirdo dan's like obsessed with
ariana grande
like bro sorry weirdo men are obsessed
with ariana grande it's like e
like back off i don't i have no idea
yeah i agree
i i find it odd like how you hide it as
if i already admit that i don't know
i mean there's not even a guess i could
have in my heart
i wrote big farts all right i'll guess
p p and big correct answer is small
barbecue grill dude that is so
dumb stupid fire everyone make fun of
ian for that
then i'll hate the ian for that question
okay
this is super easy what christmas song
is mariah carey best known for so
easy i know that one at least i'm not
it's [ __ ] brain dead
okay it's long title right
all i want for christmas is yeah correct
easy shouldn't even be in there
at least i have one iq point i have one
operating brain so
this is so much fun i like i could do
trevi all day long i love it so much
okay why is it i i don't know if you
heard me the first time but i finished
my sandwich and you still have half
years left why is that oh well actually
i never eat the butts of anything like
the ends of chicken fingers the ends of
burgers i don't like the ends of it i
like then that's a good part just don't
eat the crust
why are you hating on the end i think
it's a way to keep skinny dolly parton
once said she only eats the first
bite with peace and love it's not
working
i mean i just lost three pounds this
week thank you very much and guess what
i
just i just people i mean with love is
not working for you either whatever
you're doing and you're working out i'm
not even working out and i'm skinnier
than you scale right
now i'm not calling you fat i'm just
saying you're you're human
no but you you make tick tocks every day
this is what a chubby girl is who
doesn't want to lose weight yeah that'd
be like quirky i'm not chubby
but yeah i just think it's funny that
you're like i won't eat the ends of the
sandwich because it makes me skinny
i'm skinnier than you and who ate the
ends of their sandwich go on the tail
right now i better weigh less than you
i am fat i openly admit that and i
finish my [ __ ] sandwiches
next question how many mistresses
did tiger woods allegedly have oh
what am i keeping track of tiger woods
affairs
i mean i mean 52 right that's how many
you get in afterlife
yeah where's your wood should we have
him on the show cool tiger woods
yeah would you ever come on anything
yeah promote stuff
yeah what about o.j simpson oj for sure
oh he did block me on twitter i think oj
reached out to me one time but i don't
know if it was real or fake but i got an
email from moji simpson one time
what did he say it could be fake i did a
song about him and like i wrote a song
about him and he like
wrote to me but i don't think it might
what did he want um just congratulating
me on the song
would you go on a date with doj uh at
the time i thought about it when i was
trying to be like a troll and i probably
not now
no it'll be awesome to like go on a date
and make him wear gloves like black
gloves
that's your role play with him yeah some
girls i'm sure into that
first oh they're like we'll put on these
black gloves no there's so many girls
people like love murders look at the
menendez brothers like they get so many
fan mails
dude i was watching actually on netflix
there's a really good series called the
night stalker and this guy had all these
girls worshiping
this guy first of all he was like like a
murderer and a rapist okay
but he also and you may need to bleep
this but he
boy so he killed the dad raped the mom
and
and women are attracted to that sorry
like murdering murdering and rape is one
thing but
sorry not sex okay well there's
obviously sick people in the world oh
that's beyonce i
that is
he killed people at the hotel then at
the cecil hotel yeah i think you're
thinking of someone else
definitely the night soccer richard
ramirez that's yeah i believe
i believe trish is right because he
killed people at a hotel they didn't
mention that a documentary they didn't
mention the documentary but i know that
ahs based it off of that at one point
because he's in that season
why did they mention that in a
documentary if he was killing people at
a hotel
i don't know maybe why
it's where it's where the girl got in
the water tanks remember that
like liza lam or whatever that the asian
foreign exchange student that came over
she was in that elevator remember she
was like looking around and then she was
found in like the water towers it was
the same hotel and richard and mirrors
like killed murder bunch of people and i
was at the hotel and i almost got
murdered for real
i almost got drowned to death by a ghost
for real so ghost yeah oh
i mean i was on drugs but i definitely
think it was real because i was wet
right the drugs didn't have anything to
do with that it's a sticky situation
have you ever been trying to
be drowned by a ghost when you were
sober no
but it was at that hotel before it got
renamed to maine on stay on main or
something
all right did you put your answer 18.
what was the question again it wasn't
confirmed that it was
him i believe but he did stay at the
hotel and a lady was found strangled
yeah okay uh 11. who cares who knows
how many yeah it was eight oh i thought
eighteen because we were giving him too
much credit
step your [ __ ] up tiger woods i was so
oh god number one
18. that's a busy man
i love it i wish i was one of those
mysteries i would write books right now
i'd be like doing like press tours
just doing all just taking full
advantage of it should i just say
no i can't i feel like your career
you're elevated beyond just being a
mistress to somebody
you know what i mean i'd still take it
like joe biden's mistress like i would
be getting like book deals
i'd do it what would you say just like
about sex with him and the size of his
wiener and stuff
i don't know maybe i wouldn't be an
expert but that's not true because
you've slept with famous people and you
won't say who they are
so you have that opportunity already i
don't really love like
shaming people for sex things that are
like listening was great i just want to
make a bach off telling this private
story
i guess not shaming sorry what i don't
like to i don't know i don't like to
exploit like sexual things like if i'm
consensual
you know i don't know it feels weird
nice
okay what is the most expensive broadway
show ever produced
i know it well of course you know it
what does that mean what does that mean
of course you know
spiderman spiderman yay correct
i love that i love spiderman too i don't
know why i just loved it it was such a
disaster and everybody hated it first of
all i love it it was a bop and people
just want to hate on it
well didn't like in the one the opening
week like the main guy like broke his
back or something
yeah he definitely fell excited it made
me want to go see the show
i was like wow was it what was it a hit
financially because i thought it was
like a total
financially disaster yeah but caught
like a cult following yeah
like found it like you know what i mean
like it became like i
i wanted like no more how much did it
cost you have the 75 million oh god
how much you spent on a broadway show 75
million it's just like one
little square i never knew this about it
did you know that the music was done by
bono yeah by bono yeah
there was the budget oh um yeah there's
the budget there's 75 million right
there
um that doesn't seem like a mix to me
bono
yeah i just looked it up i was like what
the [ __ ] some people say i look like
bono
stop you literally said the last episode
you look like
samuel jackson don't i kind of look like
him today
hello hello wait there's a place called
vertigo i thought i thought you're
making a blackface joke because you said
don't i look like samuel jackson i was
like did you really just say that
after everything we've been through her
too but not today but like i've heard
that for sure
i said bono how do you look like bono
why do you say that um
i think i look like him a little bit in
what way the nose the mouth
the glasses the hair the cheekbones
can you pull up a picture of mono
oh i really do though whoa look
wait hold on go straight in the camera i
i literally
think there's no resemblance and
slightest bit it's like you
there's no resemblance no resemblance
zero we both do amazing things for this
world that's the similarity right we're
both
don't people wait don't people in
ireland hate bono because he's like a
tax evader
no i swear to making salvos
just google tax evasion bono no let's
just keep him
come on let's put the sip the tea girl
this is not the step
this is the six next question bono tax
fraud
oh my god no why are you protecting
of berno he's the king of ireland hey
let's just keep it alive we love you too
a lot of
stuff did pop up no all right
i'd have to read the articles hey for
the record like i had troubles with my
taxes
read the headline read the headlines
let's keep it moving packed rogues like
bono are harming the world's poorest oh
my god
that's a that's ruining my chances of
collabing with bono with sad 2005.
i'm so pissed about this no you're
you're interested what's happening it
was close to happening
bono's a great guy sure on sad boy 2005
by bono
yeah and let him do your taxes because
he knows what the [ __ ] up
we don't support this statement next to
me
moving on okay thank you what year did
the first episode of seinfeld
you are more protective of bono than
like shane than like shane at your peak
friendship
he's my new we do not talk [ __ ] about
bono on this podcast
what the [ __ ] is going on he's done a
lot for it like age remember
okay cool okay well let's respect i'm
just saying he doesn't pay his taxes or
something
if it's going to can you do both if it's
going to people without we should invade
he raised his money he raises he maybe
he donates all that money that he could
have put to taxes to people with aids
i guarantee that's not true i you don't
can't guarantee you don't know bono
okay bono sue me and let's do some uh
discovery bono won't even cloud with
adam sandler that's how famous he is
like adam sandler wants to club with
bono and bono's like nah
well to be fair i mean he doesn't want
to make songs about like poop and stuff
no i mean like but being in a movie dave
matthews is in adam sandler's movies why
can't bono be in it
because mine's a legend that's why
answer my own questions okay let's move
on
so dave matthews yeah he's not bono he's
definitely not bottle things he's mono
the question was what year did the first
episode of seinfeld air okay seinfeld
what a year
i know it i think i know it
i think i actually do know this why do
you why would you know this i don't know
i actually don't i think i actually know
it
you ready yep 1989 93 1989 is correct
yes you got one right over well i'm just
saying because
i love seinfeld and i finally verified
that i actually know something i care
about
i think 1989. i think did you write that
for me
somebody wrote that and thank you i
could be wrong but i think the little
chubby guy from seinfeld hit on me at
the gym one time costanza yeah
i think it was him he did not yeah i
swear like i didn't i don't watch the
show so i don't know but i think it was
him
and like so it's a small a little chubby
guy hit on you
you're not sure who it was but you think
it was alex and i think it's him
chasing that i remember seeing him from
hal where was it he lives in new york
equinox
no this was like an equinox oh but it
was in new york he lives in new york it
was like columbus circle like that
equinox
okay let's jam what's the scoreboard um
jason alexander if you can attest to
that i think it was because he was like
did you were you receptive because he's
really famous and rich
um yeah i'm receptive to everyone i give
everyone my number like if you guys know
me all right did he ask for your number
yeah
and he never called you no you got
shaded by him
oh but you know what i don't answer
calls that are from like maybe he
blocked his number like a number i
didn't know so
damn jason had a shot i think that's
awesome
i don't know anyway i'm just really
proud that i got that right so thank you
you think we're only four behind right
now
okay that's that's not bad wasn't there
a racism seinfeld
then the guy said the n-word to like a
bunch of like on his comedy stand-up
routine oh kramer yeah
so we can't support that show well
that's kramer i'm gonna support bono
evading taxes giving it to aids then
kramer had a moment he's not even he's
just an actor are you gonna just
he's apologized wow
what braid of dog is scooby doo what the
hell
[Laughter]
i'm gonna discuss this i don't know
anything about dogs unless you're a
pomeranian
scooby doo looking at he doesn't look
like anything just like some cartoon bro
scoop
yeah i feel like the ears kind of made
me look like a specific breed
i don't really think my dogs either so
don't come for me
i'm just taking a guess here okay ready
yep great dane doberman great dane
i'm coming back what are you at great
dane
dude no yeah he does what's the score
it is 13 16 13. oh
i'm coming back this is the best game
ever okay
okay i came together now i got to focus
i was like yeah you better get you
better get into better bad for you
who are the two individuals involved in
2004's super bowl
nipple gate oh nibble nipple gate
oh it sounds like he's a nibble i feel
like you can see my answers maybe that's
why you're doing better i'm not looking
at your answers stop
can i just say why do i need two i know
whose nipple was
but you have to put the other person
involved yeah
there was oh my god wow you really don't
know anything about anything
you know now you're angry because i'm
right on your heels what is that tv show
you know nothing
what's the name of the ramen hair guy oh
i remember
oh my god stupid
okay we both got it janet jackson and
justin timberlake
okay correct okay
everything's all right is a song in
which andrew lloyd
whoever removed what song which
everything's all right is a song in
which andrew lloyd webber musical
everything's all right the [ __ ] you say
everything's alright i heard you okay
everything's all right
it's a musical yeah
you don't know i don't know [ __ ] wow and
i like know everything about andrew
lloyd webber this is actually i don't
know
it has to be one that i don't what's his
most famous play
well his most famous is probably
oh he made phantom god oh so he's some
people
don't like him generally speaking what
people don't like him
because those are shitty i'm gonna just
guess what i haven't i don't know a lot
about because it's definitely not fake
everything's all right
oh my god i can put something i i know i
got it wrong so you should just put
something
everything's all right wow this is
broadway and i [ __ ] suck so
i can't even think of something to guess
um
oh oh oh
oh i was going to guess that is that him
is that an angel
story oh that's not what i was going to
guess okay
incorrect the answer is jesus christ
dude you got a broadway one wrong you're
giving me a chance here
you're right don't panic whatever you do
don't panic
keep it together i panicked that bono i
was going to see this
i'm so annoyed now cut it out dan cut
that part about
the whole discussion oh my god you guys
watching bono is like busy on a yacht
somewhere told me brad pitt watches this
podcast and i'm not i'm not lying brad
who told you that i mean someone told me
but if brad pitt is watching his podcast
he better have some better [ __ ] to do
with his life
bradford is not watching this podcast i
actually know that's kind of credible
but can you imagine brad pitt watching
this
you're fantasizing i did hear a theory
that tarantino watches this
because he has a foot fetish and he has
trisha and you
you took the number one spot on uh yeah
he's watching closely
hey maybe we talk about israel
exactly yeah that's good yeah no get
quentin
don't [ __ ] that's my hebrew okay you
don't know hebrew i could say so much
and you have no idea i'm learning so
much hebrew
i know it's great i mean it's it's
awesome okay if you answer his next one
and he will get bonus points
which artists tried selling his own
video game console until being
threatened by with legal action by
nintendo
wait which artist yeah which artists
tried selling their own video game
console until being threatened with
legal action god i know this what kind
of artist like a
like a like i don't know what do you
mean
what kind of artist are we talking about
ants
what do you think about answering that
question maybe
you ask questions all the time well
i don't know any artist except for ela
klein that's the only artist i know
that's a nice
she's good she's talented do you think
you're as talented as her
ela is no not even close
yeah i don't think i'm just talented not
only she talented she's like hard
working she's
focused she's even-headed you're doing
like too much girl you are doing too
much
i wrote are you ready oh oh i i don't
have i'm gonna just i'm just gonna guess
this is the only artist i really know
for real
i wrote soulja boy banksy soulja boy's
correct yes
soldier boy soldier boy
from 90 oh yeah i forgot
there was this nigerian dude a 90 day
fiance who was like a wannabe
musical artist what's happening all the
time why
we have whatsapp together that's one
that you were talking about what who's
that who's that
rapper what song i don't know kiss me
through the phone
kiss me through the phone um okay so
wait it's a two-point game now
this is exciting it's like last time
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
it was three i just got one right she
got one wrong moses what is this
she did not get soulja boy the one
before that she did not get wrong oh
yeah i didn't get that moses moses moses
moses baby they both got they both got
the super bowl question right
i'm losing my mind over here you
25 was jesus christ superstar they
didn't they both got that right i am
so 16 no 16 no
no everything is in quote
i mean this is losing my mind so cool
you're the first lawyer to endorse my
brand thank you
i love you i actually like your music a
lot really yeah
i haven't listened to the second one yet
the second one's better that's i
i'm going to watch it today oh we can
maybe at the end we'll watch it together
do a little previewing you know what's
weird is i do get weird like showing
people my music i'm someone i'm not that
person like look at my videos
oh yeah i know what you mean it's just
hot but i want to watch it so many
people are like here look at my video
and you're just like awkwardly there
you're just like
i'm gonna let's watch it after
these guys are in the lab doing okay
1614 who did jada pickett smith reveal
she had an entanglement with
a table man who remembers that guy
that's like a ryland like who knows him
like
yeah he was just some [ __ ] some
dumbass
i mean he had some what are you asking
some red table trivia i mean this is
does she even count as pop culture i
mean come on they're on facebook and
um i literally you don't know because i
don't know
okay well i'm gonna make a guess because
i think this might be or someone close
to this name
it's nothing antoine johnson no the
answer is
wait isn't that the isn't that the truth
yeah
that's the guy hard on your people
isn't antoine or something
there's someone out here raping
everybody out here
he's on tick tock now he's on tick tock
he's killing what was the answer
i don't know i never know how to
pronounce the last name august azalea is
just some random dude i'm supposed to
know his name nice
that's like such that's like literally
like sorry
nobody knows what do you expect that who
is uh ringo starr's second cousin
fiance on facebook next anyway you
should know the original drummer of the
beatles like that's
okay easy thank you oh yeah
don't care about them our last six
presidents
name our last six presidents interesting
including the new one
uh not including the new one former
president
oh my god i hate this
it's a little fuzzy for me at some point
here same
oh okay hmm
oh i think i i know it i know it i know
it it
is yeah yeah yeah gonna say
yeah i think i think i got it
i'm 99 on this one how many one how many
six
all right trump obama
george w bush clinton bush senior reagan
ford
[Laughter]
how was he still alive reagan was
president reagan was president yeah
oh my god that how i was like ford's
still alive right he's got to be
what stuff [ __ ] does habitat for
humanity oh carter
yeah carter he was before uh
reagan i beat you at a political
question oh my god
oh reagan [ __ ] me i didn't wasn't even
on the radar simi valley the reagan
library
reagan [ __ ] i should have known that
reaganomics okay i feel like ian's
trolling you guys at this point but
what is selena what is it a selena
question no
no gomez what did elon musk
and grimes originally named their baby
oh god that's stupid
you know it i mean i i have an idea but
like who could actually recite
verbatim can i read the answer dan oh i
don't know it was like
oh well i can say it you know what i
feel like i should get a point because i
know how it's pronounced
that i don't know how to spell it but i
know how it's pronounced why is elon
musk such a big deal that counts right i
think they should count right yeah
because i can't read it well since when
do i have to spell [ __ ] right i always
spell everything wrong but i know how to
say it
okay it's a good point it was ash
that is how you pronounce it how did you
say it
but he spelled it like all crazy with
like letters that
that like when you mash the keyboard and
there's like secret letters that come
out
you know what i mean i don't like
something i've kind of flipped on him i
used to be a huge stan and now i don't
like him
okay so i got the point so it's back to
two okay so
moving on will i am as a member of what
band
that's easy oh that you know yeah i
didn't know new music
i just used to make fun of william a lot
so i kind of know about him remember he
punched press hilton in the face where
is president he did
yeah it was crazy black guy
yeah correct how many questions we have
left we have 10 remain or 9 remaining oh
this is coming down to the wire two
points
two away i'm two apart who sings
despacito
actually i'm saying like that i actually
don't know if i know it really
oh i know the answer it's uh the eagles
despacito
why won't you come to your senses
you act like you're like 55 years old
all the time why because a bad joke
and cnn and politics and everything like
everything about you is just like i'm
16.
okay and you act like you're 16 when you
go
after every word i have unresolved
trauma from 16 that's why i revert back
to it that's what my therapist says it's
my way of coping with the trauma
so thanks for putting that up well i
have five year was really dark and
that's why i dress like this and act
like this
it wasn't just a phase mom
i might i didn't comment on the fact
that you have like a pseudo mask on what
is that
oh i'm cosplaying who do you think i'm
cross playing today uh batman obviously
i think that i hate you i don't know who
donatello ninja turtle
leonardo are you i'm not whatever who is
it
does anybody know yes moses not you
obviously you know
let me show you the picture first hold
on this is my this is my cosplay today
i am gerard way from the revenge era oh
you're still the same
no i was danger james gerard way last
time now i'm revenge
same guy it's a different era okay
okay well it looks esposito is by um
honestly dude i don't [ __ ] know
dustin bieber no no justin bieber
justin bieber he's featured
he's featured in the remix yeah that's
literally no
he did it no it's are you kidding me who
wrote it
i know it's not justin bieber it's some
latin it's some latin band right
in spanish song
he's not in the original no you didn't
always take a point for being combative
minus one point
all right who's at least who's the lead
singer of the band queen
oh my god really why would you even ask
rami malik obviously
who wrote why would you even write that
can we get bonus points for his
nationality
the the real dirty mercury malec what
no you know it's freddy it's freddie
mercury you look like this one of you
right
he he's pakistani no he's from some
weird like indian
some weird indian he's pakistani oh oh
he's pakistani i believe maybe he's not
pakistani dude
oh what are you what why would you say
his real name is farooq which is arab so
are your parents like his parents or
they're like yeah we're brothers
he's lebanese it's like not even close
it's close it's all the middle east
everyone tells me
yeah the comment section always says i
look like romney malek so you do
like romney malek i think he creeps me
out look we are not a roman alexander on
this podcast
sorry uh well i'm actually not even
gonna argue with you on that one i think
he's weird
okay so what is still two points yes
okay give me a good one which mercury
come on
which celebrity thought chicken of the
sea was actually chicken
how do you know this one you're like oh
i got this one i don't know why but i do
we're the same brain we know the same
pop culture references ready
jessica simpson boom okay come on what
was the name of a show that she centered
on
newlyweds who was she married to nicolas
okay chill
there's no bonus points remember i love
jessica simpson
uh who's losing our queen which
celebrity was photographed dangling a
baby off their balcony
oh my god that's so easy who did these
questions
ian did this one just to [ __ ] with me
that's why oh
wow i guess he was thinking it might
have stumped me but i know it's michael
jackson
correct which actor was found
masturbating in an adult film theater
and subsequently arrested i felt bad for
him because
i always felt like he got kind of played
dirty it's like what do you expect
people to do in adult film everyone's
jerking right right right they made a
scene like there's one
movie they ruined his whole life like
everybody's in there jerking off i think
he got some redemption arc when he was
like in blow and stuff i think we were
like oh yeah he's kind of dope now
he got some crud i don't know his name
but you're to give me the point
you have to see his name herman pee wee
herman didn't get caught in the
in the thing you have to say his name
you have to say his name you have to say
it that's the rule
it's phoebe herman paul rubens
both answers are acceptable oh my gosh
oh these are your employees no they're
like these guys want to see me
oh my god you heard dan he's giving up
bonus points left and right willy-nilly
five bonus points by now
so game okay during an interview with
oprah
which athlete admitted to doping
throughout their entire career
wait a minute tell what doping doping
doping like like writing
juicing i'm sorry you do not get the
defined doping for trisha
yeah cause i don't think he said oh i've
been doping this whole time he probably
said something else
lancer mark maguire one point
oh no lance armstrong is that he's
missing a testicle what's the uh
the score yeah he was he was injecting
steroids right it is
currently 21 20. okay so wait we're
it's one point do those cancel each
other out then he did steroids but he
had cancer
i was like all right we'll forgive him i
mean the thing is everybody was doing
steroids during that time so he's still
you know he doesn't look like he's on a
roids he looked skinny even on a bike
they it wasn't like
muscles it was like they would take they
would take this medicine that like
ex gave you more red blood cells so you
had like more endurance because you have
more energy
some weird crazy and it's more of an
enhancement uh performance enhancement
tom green also has one testicle i think
he had cancer too
oh so sad bone spun do you get checked
do you get checked i check myself
like every day in the shower one time i
i felt that well what are you doing like
once a week i don't think it's gonna
change
that much anyway i i once felt a lump
and i was like i'm
[ __ ] have to i definitely have cancer
but it was a vein
yeah i could see you being like a
hypochondriac like just thinking no it
was weird like there was like a vein
bunched up on my ball which i never felt
before
yeah it was just a vein and i just like
and then it smoothed out and i was like
oh thank god
so okay bonus point for me no bonus
point just because yeah
trisha is leading by one we have five
questions remaining
yes which two celebrities were caught on
a security camera fighting in an
elevator
oh
i'm that doesn't i have no recollection
of that
um say it again which two celebrities
were caught on security camera fighting
in an elevator
moses put another point jay-z and
schlonge knowles
that is jay-z was scrapping with
somebody now beyonce
beyonce's sister yeah wait he beat the
[ __ ]
no she started like kicking him and [ __ ]
and she was kicking him in the elevator
he didn't
strike back i don't think so thank god
you can't strike back
yeah i think you guys did watch it once
well according to hereby j if you're gay
you can i guess just remember who's
writing these questions
who is writing these questions yeah and
he's a hip-hop fan
he's won back to three points i'm
running out of time here
two two two okay which olympic
swimmer made up a story about being
robbed at gunpoint in brazil oh
why do you know that how do you not know
that i don't know anything about the
olympics and i know this
i mean i remember the story but he's not
a famous swimmer is he
no no hands he's just some guy everyone
just it's not just a guy if he's an
olympian michael phelps is the only
swimmer anybody knows and i know it's
time i have no idea who this is i'm out
yeah i've never heard of this okay then
i don't know either for microphones
yeah no i know it's not i know it's not
michael phelps yeah
yeah what's his name ryan lachey
lush piece of [ __ ] okay
after six different nominations leonardo
dicaprio finally won an oscar for which
film
oh [ __ ] my life um
[Music]
i know it but i don't know the name
he lost to joaquin for the joker [ __ ] it
he should have won for that i love once
more
and hollywood what were we going to do
was good i was thinking of that movie
but i couldn't remember the name so i
kind of
i know i was too i was like wait wait
wait wait wait wait i saw it
it was kind of boring so boring it's
just him leaving forever is a little
overrated in my opinion like good but
overrated
he's a good actor but hmm i think he's
kind of worried he's not like amazing i
think he's good he's average
he's never gonna come on this pumpkin he
don't want leo
on his podcast he thinks global
warming's fake or something
no he's he has a huge initiative for
global pro
he is okay he's missing you have an
opposite okay the other way though he's
more extreme about global warming like
just chill bro you're just looking for
any reason to hate
fire right now wait hold on you just
said i hate him because he doesn't
believe in going
the other way away he's a little extreme
about global warming
i think that's a good idea and you
choose to collaborate with david dobrik
as your first social media
that's why you're here yeah he's like
let me take a picture
next to david dobrik to say go vote is
that really collab
he's not even a citizen he can't even
vote why are you collabing with him to
go vote like what the hell
you really hate david you really hate
david he's a straight person i think
shitty people who doesn't take
accountability if you're a shitty person
to combat
learn grow cool but if you don't
accountability you can just be a person
for your life
not cool but the only the puzzle is the
only thing he's ever done that i think
is great oh my god do you really want me
to go into a dissertation about why
david dobrik
give me one other big reason
i mean there's so many other ones do you
want to forgive me i mean he pushed a
joke that made me uncomfortable multiple
times in his log and i told him
specifically
what was the joke people he was trying
to get jason to literally have sex with
hannah he was like i'll buy you like a
ferrari like trisha what kind of oh
that's [ __ ] up no he's like what can i
do he brought tina over one night that's
why i blew up on him he's like tana come
over i'm gonna i'm gonna try and
convince trish to have a threesome for
the vlog like he
and i asked him so many times like this
is like really like messing me up yeah
that's super
ew that's horrible [ __ ] up in so many
ways like any time i've asked like he's
he's the worst he
is awful he's just that's disgusting i
don't like that behavior yeah it's like
bro you can't play with people's lives
for your [ __ ] vlogs he even brought
tan over and said i'm uncomfortable with
this and he still was pushing it and
he's so uncle
well it was kind of up to jason though
to say dude don't do this no i told
david cause he was jason did
jason totally did he did yeah jason's
like stopped this is like not cool and
like david still was like pushing it but
he's like sucks david's teeth so he's
just like all right
whatever i don't like david and also he
filmed that 24 year old brandon cavill
like
on a date with a 17 year old asking the
17 year old if sex is cool with brandon
like promoting all this creativity i
don't know what you're talking about
okay well there's a ton of there's a ton
of things online you can check it out
he's gross next how many questions we
got left
no point for that bonus point for
hitting david so we have a little bit of
a problem what's the problem
you're behind by three and there's only
two questions remaining i thought i was
mine by two
three so you got the revenant oh the
remnant okay well
let's just finish it and see how bad it
gets
okay which controversial soft drink was
released in 1992 and taken out of
circulation
after being publicly rejected being
rejected by the public
what year 1992 could you say that the
question
which controversial soft drink was
released in 1992
and taken out of circulation after being
rejected by the public
i'm just taking a shot in the dark here
after being rejected by the public okay
crystal pepsi i was gonna say that is he
right
he is correct i always said surge why
were people angry about crystal pepsi i
always thought it was cool
yeah i was confused because that i
that's like yeah okay
okay so hey i'm coming back to the the
impossible comeback can i
make a suggestion next week can we get
surge you can get it off ebay can we try
it
it's just coke i mean it's not that
interesting no it's not surge isn't coke
search is like
something oh it is no okay is this the
last one
this is the last one if i get if i get
this right we have to do
can we get it this podcast is sponsored
it's like the timing sketch where
they're bleeding out the eyes surge
i was on the geminic show you didn't put
that in my compilation i know
i didn't put that i didn't put that
together music video
i didn't i didn't put it together i was
surprised someone [ __ ] up someone
dropped the ball now
for sure it was a fan-made one oh god
okay let's let's hear the last one okay
over it
so are we agreeing to this being double
points i agree
yeah i'm in yeah i've been sure oh good
sport what a good sport okay
what's the name so this is it yes this
is it okay
we're all in what's the name of the
infamous haircut inspired by the show
friends oh oh my god i thought you hate
friends
i hate friends i never seen in one
episode and i know this infamous haircut
inspired by friends
should do would you guys both agree on a
hint
no absolutely not i actually have it i
agree on a hint
what the hell i already got the answer
it's like give me a hand you already won
you won you won you won give me a hit
it's named after one of the main
characters
well i don't know i don't know which one
it is the jerry
i have a feeling it has to do with ross
though mm-hmm
no it's not that the chandler no that
doesn't ring
hmm and then the other guy i think
people want to look like rush
to raw oh i mean i guess he ross is kind
of a stud well
no he's a good phone yeah who cares i
don't watch foreign
that is the correct it is the rachel
[Applause]
[Music]
i love winning oh my god jesus
ah it was closer than you thought it
would be
yeah for sure but again it's down to the
wire people deal with anything it goes
to [ __ ] like the back my
season of the bachelor went to [ __ ]
because your people picked it dude
you're engaged what are you talking
about you're engaged you just bought a
house
with your fiance good point tough with
this [ __ ] how dare you
women okay cool we did it i won i love i
always win though like i've never like
lost
you lost the last time that wasn't pop
quarter trippy and that was a little
[ __ ] first of all for all the
[ __ ] talking you were doing the fact
that i narrowed it down to even one
point
is kind of a w for me you are okay thank
you
thank you we'll have to what's up so
i'll do math and science next time
stupid that first time it was like i was
close to you and it was all those like
categories that were the same thing like
history geography like it all had to do
with the same [ __ ] it's like it needs to
be more varied i'm down i loved it
how come they have so many views like
who's watching that episode again like
oh let's watch i used more than 5th
grader that was so boring that one was
so boring oh my god chill
why are you making fun of our audience
they like it don't argue with that let
them watch
what what do we call this one are you
smarter than
a soccer mom i don't know what's the
trivia you know
are you smart oh i don't know this is
hard
is ethan smarter than trisha i don't
know we'll figure it out we'll do some
or i could just call it like shane has
literally can't shane just
or i saw one video go shane just ruined
his comeback
i like it but d'angelo wallace's next
video maybe it was
the exact moment just come back how
about
shane and roilyn
ryland yeah literally just got arrested
just
makes it up yeah buy buy the internet
please so it technically is an arrest
okay technically okay before we wrap it
up first of all i want to oh let's watch
your music video
okay before that teddy fresh thursday
care bears release is coming out we'll
look we'll look at it um
together on um sadboy2005.com
and mulholland drive is out now okay
let's watch it
do you want to watch it on yours and
bring it up i'll watch it on my phone
because it's connected oh it has um
72 000 views right now thank you guys
for the love what
what yeah recast it yeah
you're not gonna like it though if
you're not like you know an emo music
you're not gonna like love
well i'm i'm interested okay here we go
okay sad boy 2005 trisha paytas reveals
their brand new
music video wrong side of mulholland
drive oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if we're gonna look back on this [ __ ]
like you know like 20 years
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] this gender i'm going to
another gender
[Music]
[Applause]
kind of weird
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two story lines happening in this video
okay you got an a in a b plot yay
[Music]
[Applause]
dude he can't even put through this
archway with his little cherokee
headphones
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's just not fair that society doesn't
accept you guys you don't fit in
it's not what happening is about
transforming something different i was a
dumb girl and i'm a hot sexy evil
[Music]
i could have told you that
[Music]
good song good videos
[Music]
[Laughter]
um i think it's really good thanks i
have to get i have to say something yeah
positive about you
it was very very you were very prolific
like you do
so much i'm just i'm very impressed wait
what do you mean what's prolific
prolific means that you do so much
like you're doing music you're doing
videos you're doing you know you're
doing only fans you're making youtube
videos like you're you do a lot it's
impressive
and i mean it takes guts to go out there
and make music i mean i know
it's not easy to put yourself out there
like that i'm impressed
thanks i think it's just like being
unhappy i'm just trying to find
something to fill a void
yeah but still like sometimes when i'm
unhappy or i feel like
i'm looking for sometimes i just i don't
have the
i don't still go out there and do it so
it's impressive that you do it
oh thanks that's so nice so we should
give dixie to credit too cause dixie's
doing it
pixie oh dixie that's emilio oh we gotta
give her credit she's not i don't know
if
she can get the title as prolific
because literally all she does is this
her time off when she's not making music
i said tick tock dance
they do the macarena did you see her dad
his comment on the bahamas trip he's
such a weirdo he's like we had to do
what we had to do
by going to the bahamas basically he's
like [ __ ] you suck my dick
my girls are famous i'm a cloud demon
i'm a clout goblin
could you imagine when theater was like
17 you're just like trying to like be in
all the whatever's the new tick tock and
you're like
so embarrassed so embarrassing i would
never if my kids are cool on an
album you go be cool like you know who
does that is not that she's anybody but
candace cameron not no offense because
she's like sweet but you know candace
cameron
dj tanner from full house she's like in
all her daughters tic-tocs and like a
little cringe it's like
why do they allow that why do the
parents allow this i mean the kids why
are the kids allowed
me to be like mom get the [ __ ] out of my
dick you [ __ ]
i think it's clout or something maybe i
don't know anyway
what kind of kid thinks having your
parents in your videos clown that's like
the anti-clout
it's like the clout hole it's a black
hole that sucks cloud out of you the
cloud hole
can i i can't thanks for everything i
came across something that i need to
so you hate jack's film and we found we
did some investigating journalism
oh no and we feel like jose yeah a
little bit
wait you still have my phone down what's
gonna happen oh my god i'm scared
i love being ambushed though you do yeah
it gives me like an adrenaline rush like
i'm on edge now what did i say
well this is pretty solid really you
keep saying you don't like jack's film
oh wow and you know we we dug into the
history a little bit you got it dan
who dug into this 2012.
who did you say jack's film says when i
get back in la i want to do way more
collabs sound good and you said yep i'll
be over okay thanks bye
you were begging mm-hmm you were like a
weird fan of jack's films
i got rejected i think but you were
acting like you don't know who he is and
you're acting like
you're like begging him for a collapse
on twitter like pathetic [ __ ]
wait let me tell him multiple times
through shane
hold on hold on hold on he says who
wants to be in my next music video want
to shoot this weekend or sooner you said
me please
oh oh my god there's multiple tweets
again oh i'm
back in l.a let's make questionable
choices together you said yes
now you can make a ygs what's ygs
your grammar sucks oh see you and your
grammar sucks every single day
oh [ __ ] bro you're a stan and you're mad
that he didn't acknowledge you
that's [ __ ] up you're going to delete
all my tweets like you i'm going to just
be like he's leaning on oh my god this
is the best thing i ever did
and then he again in 2013 a year later
hey youtube gals who would like to be my
girl in my upcoming dubstep
solves everything free video me i'm your
biggest fan jack
no seriously though read it for yourself
what year is this
me i'm your biggest fan jack team
well seriously though embarrassing oh
[ __ ] i'm getting flogged so what the f
so and i think it's just time to come
clean that
he just rejected yeah kids do wait well
so
can you confess that jack did not want
to [ __ ] you
he's he's i think that was ever the
question brutally rejected the question
was that he wanted to [ __ ] me i don't
think that was the
is debatable if he's a true man i think
he's
a poor boy he's married i don't consider
him a man i think he's
like a child but but you were coming on
to him like very hard we saw it you were
begging him like pathetic [ __ ]
i see your point um
i just have to stand up for my boy jack
here a little bit i think i'll have to
uh give you an answer on the next
episode okay think about it
come back to me with a good job i'm sure
i have something in my files from him so
i'm gonna
look i'm gonna do a little investment
okay good that'll be interesting
something to look forward to
yeah he's like how did i get in the
middle of this [ __ ] he's the worst you
ever hear from him about it
no he's saying no jack is not the
japanese
word he's literally not the worst times
me more than anybody i met will gibson
three times and he remembered me jack's
films can't be bothered to like remember
that he dude he doesn't know who you are
you've been tweeting at him he never
responds
no i met him three times to shane i met
him at the stream he's next to david
dobrik we were sitting at the same table
right next to each other he doesn't know
who you are that's some
serious [ __ ] that's serious [ __ ]
you're just so insulted by the fact he
doesn't know who you are
and he never responded to you i mean
look i
listen it's sad you're a fan of a guy
you love him you look up to him he
doesn't acknowledge you
you're like the guy from the m m video
oh
dope i love stan yeah that's cool one
is that what stands from from the
eminent video it literally is oh wow i
worked it out because i didn't know
either
wow what a tour de force of cultural
influence
i mean i'm killing it a stan is not a
good thing though because they use it
like
it's like a stand for everyone bono stan
but stan
if you examine the music video stan is
kind of a psycho
obsessed over-obsessed only want fans
that are obsessed with me i don't want
middle-of-the-road pussyfoot
patricia wasn't stan like like
kind of like psycho murder go of your
double gate obsessed
i think eminem just didn't give him you
know any attention
give your fans attention give your
stance attention that's moderate do not
feed the stands
i give people attention you want to
reach out to me i'm here don't your
biggest don't say that
you literally just said people are
breaking into my house i'm scared that
was an h3 stand that came for me it
wasn't a tristan
sorry h3 stands don't break any why
would i age three on the police report
him texting that he was like saw me on
the h3 podcast and he stands you and
that's why he came on the show
so why would he why would he go to your
house and not my house if he's such a
stan
no he saw me on the show because he's an
h3 stan like that was his verbiage and
he came to my house because he said that
he saw me on h3 that i needed love and
he had to love me before i was about to
die and i was like what the [ __ ]
i disavow him you also just but it
happened twice you said it happened
twice
yeah it did happen twice and are they
both hd stands no
no i didn't say [ __ ] so trisha so
goes i'll give out money to anybody just
hit me up
and now she's saying hit me up first you
gotta chill dude
first of all some very clever so many
people and i and i some people
gave me video messages back thanking me
for their money a lot of my fans don't
thank me for the money that i give them
but why are you giving out money who'd
you give money to a lot of people and
they gave me videos back and they were
so sweet
and they were like oh my gosh thank you
trish the you know who were smart
because i got so many after that show
and the smart ones were the ones who put
my chemical romance lyrics in the title
so i i paid out everyone who gave me my
chemical romance lyrics and
it would kind of tell you emails [ __ ]
forever though now why
how much did you give them i think 500
to each person what
moses you gotta hold your you guys what
you got mortgages and [ __ ] now you can't
be just passing out five hundred dollars
people mean why
that's a lot of money how much money did
you she was the savior of the broken
and she like how much money did you give
away
i don't think that's like 5k she was so
happy like she gave me this whole video
saying hi
you got it you gotta you gotta chill
i mean what happened to oh i'm a
socialist let's give out our money to
the poor people like let's
do it i want okay give away all your
money you're right i just won
two thousand dollars trans equality
you're getting this and also anyone who
i want
i want the government i like the ones
who give me like some backup people
providing receipts they're like hey this
is my negative five hundred dollar bank
account i was like oh [ __ ]
i can photoshop that [ __ ] you know i
gave away a hundred thousand dollars on
twitter and
there was almost no but there was a few
people gave me genuine thanks but a lot
of people were like
oh really didn't thank you no that's not
true
i got a couple of really nice messages
but some of the stuff was like some
people didn't even respond
yeah but that was like so nice i love
that you did that but i was also like
hell annoying because like on the
twitter was just oh here's our winners
here's our winners
okay let's do it on a different platform
but great i love that you did it that's
why you didn't even i wasn't doing
podcasts or anything at the time so
twitter is kind of the only thing i had
and you deleted all the tweets to hide
the evidence
yes you remember when you were getting
so pissed that i was like tweeting in
hebrew and you're like what the [ __ ]
no yeah you talked about the podcast you
were getting so pissed i wasn't so
pissed oh my god you guys made like five
episodes about it about me saying like
something in hebrew like love and you're
like oh my god there's a [ __ ]
no get the [ __ ]
do a compilation of every time ethan was
like annoyed about something i tweeted
that had nothing to do with him
they're all erased but the h3 podcast
you talk about okay find the time
like you have nothing better to do with
your time i mean people be digging
people be finding the craziest [ __ ] from
back
teddyfresh.com i support that
next week we can look at everything
together if you're okay with that okay
what well because
it comes out this thursday at 5 00 am
and i want to i like to look at the
photos like we did last time was fun
i have nothing to promote next week oh
but next week starts
valentine's day month so i guess we need
a
do you have any sport videos you want to
promote only to shock i'll promote next
week
let's get some squirt videos out there
okay that's good right
that probably nets you the most money
but yeah no but people know where to
find it
but you probably make the most money
when you when we promote your only fans
right oh yeah
oh yeah okay next time we'll do a whole
little promo i'll do something special
for the friend of mine do something
crazy like pooping on moses
you can't do that on frenemies can you i
mean you can't do that on the only pants
you can't poop on only fans no or
pornhub or any of those things
didn't that one girl the fetish girl say
she were pooping
we talked to a fetish girl on after dark
who says she did this thing called fruit
looping do you know what that is no
those were commissioned videos oh it
wasn't through only fans so
she could get her account deleted you
can't sell them either you know what
fruit looping is
she they're acting like this is common
knowledge it's when you prolapse your
butthole
and then eat fruit oh that is why no
numbering that is why i don't choose to
watch the h3 podcast because it's
disgusting are you learning things this
is educational
cultural uh trivia next time we do
cultural trivia
what is fruit looping it's an important
question now everybody at home knows
prolapsing the anus and eating fruit
loops
i guess just gaping just gaping gabriel
i have a gaping butthole gaping
buttholes and
fruit loops out of the gaping bottle and
she told me they had to put a sponge in
to hold the milk
because the ass is just too absorbent
uh if that's true she'll get kicked off
only fan so i hope she didn't say her
name
all right well that's the episode
yep so i hope you guys enjoyed
trisha wins this time very well played
good job yeah who shelly
we should just talk hebrew and then we
could say what you want to say they have
letters on it sad boy
oh there's my logo nice oh that's
awesome
thanks how do you get that done um a
really good
nail artist his name is john legend he
does all the kardashians he's very good
yeah
he's great how much should cost to get
your nails done like that
900 but i give him a good tip he i think
normally he's like
i don't know i don't know but i give him
a tip because he comes from a house he's
great he's accommodating and welcome
how long does it take to do that a few
hours
he's dope mr snappy over here yeah
fantastic thanks oh okay oh we can't
announce anything anyways
we can't say it for a while nevermind
okay
thank you next week guys shout out to
honey
i wish we had tater tots maybe next time
no i can't do the tater tots i'm trying
to lose weight
what is valentine's day month month
you want a whole month of eating 14. all
right guys
bye bye
you